le TVB qui s'incline face à la à la Rago
de cette 3,7 ans justement hier au
Palais des Sports et mousser affaibli
par l'absence de Raphaël redwig c'est un
Loïc de kergria diminué le tour
volley-ball n'a été que l'ombre de
lui-même hier après-midi après sa très
bonne prestation mercredi à bellegorod
les hommes d'erican gapet perdent
sèchement les deux premiers 7 25 17 et
25 7 et 25 16 excusez-moi un sursaut
d'orgueil et deux panache leur livre la
troisième manche 25 17 mais ce sont
finalement les c'est toi qui s'imposent
dans le quatrième set 28 26 du coup le
TVB laisse la première place au
classement à la scan qui a gratté un
point à Paris voler les tours enjaux
comptent 11 points après 5 journées